the Joe Rogan experience well psychiatry
psychiatry is the enemy of Scientology
they have all these big signs that
psychiatry kills and it's like someone
with like an electric [ __ ] shock
thing in their head it's like in
Hollywood like they're they're on this
crusade against against psychiatry it's
like a big part of what Scientology is
the thing that makes me laugh is that I
don't see a lot of southern
Scientologists I don't see a lot of
Scientology Florida the big things in
Clearwater are they go that's the number
one headquarters in Clearwater that's my
sister lives down there
she lives real close to where the number
of the headquarters is it's [ __ ]
weird down there man everybody just
they're all walking like they got a
secret do you do you think in this
society do you think Scientology will be
the last religion created like when you
really think about how recent
Scientology is it's like the 1940s or
50s somewhere like it's roughly the same
age it's like United Airlines it's not
an old religion we have videos of the
guy who made it yeah yeah will that be
the last religion that it's like created
no because every other religion it's
like old school you know centuries and
millenniums old but no there'll be new
ones the interesting thing is they're
probably the last ones to get task tax
exempt status because their status is
being questioned right now there's
people that are very angry about it but
they did it because they they all
started lawsuits against the IRS and
they start thousands of lawsuits the
idea was that they were going to sue the
IRS into recognizing them as a
legitimate religion and the way to do
that was just overwhelm them with
litigation and that's what they did
right they're still doing this what they
did they then they achieved tax-exempt
status a long time ago they're they're
very it's a very strange did you ever
read going clear I saw the yeah it's the
dock is great the book is even crazier
because Lawrence Wright goes into depth
with all these different people that
look like as they were realizing that it
was horseshit like as they were getting
like the the ninth level of doom
open up its handwritten nonsense by a
[ __ ] like that that guy who wrote it
was a he was self he was like self
diagnosing all of his his own personal
ailments and dealing with them himself
and then trying to like pass that off as
like a way to live amongst all these
people that were paying attention to him
but all of it started from him from
himself diagnosing is it is it natural
for Scientologists and I'm only I only
know what I know from that doc and Leah
Remini in lifetime she is it natural to
not be like the way a Christian is just
openly Christian just hey how you doing
the Lord loves you I'm here to tell you
about Jesus I don't really feel like to
get that from science I'd like normally
like watching that doc I didn't know the
dude from Chicago PD used to be like the
gritty yeah detective guy yeah I know he
used to be a Scientologist like you
never find out that somebody was
Internet it until after they're out of
it now I think people keep it tough
it's not like Mormons where they're
riding the bikes and you know what the
[ __ ] the deal is right yeah now they
keep it tucked in but I think back in
the day they used to talk about it as
openly as pop they've proselytize
they try to get you to join but how like
just come just try to try to get people
to come to these events try to get
people to come to these free workshops
all these different things on anxiety
different things on the mind Dianetics
that's what he just decided to write
about Dianetics and there's like the
science of cleaning your mind and
avoiding all external influences that
are negative and that are ruin your your
perspective and you should be
commercials for that Haiti's in 97 I
bought it I bought a Dynex book I got
our list with the volcano exploding the
commercial I really bought everything
man I bought Tony Robbins [ __ ] I bought
all kind but book of five rings I've got
[ __ ] art of war I bought everything I
was just trying to figure out like
what's the best I was into psychology
when I was young because fighting all
the time and I was always scared so I
was trying to figure out this gotta be a
way to like overcome these mental
hurdles like does that was like for
martial arts competition the big thing
was the fear it wasn't your physical
ability wasn't as much of a hurdle as
the
fear you know if the the fear of
competition was terrible I was like it's
good but sometimes I feel confident and
it'd be great and other times it'd be
[ __ ] terrified and like I gotta
figure out how to be consistent so I
started getting into all that kind of
stuff and then when I came to LA it's
like in 94 I saw a Dianetics commercial
said [ __ ] it I'll order that so I got
behind the way the questions you seek
the answers to here it is Kenward said
during an operation harm you later page
182 is it possible to increase
intelligence page 122 I was like oh my
god yeah look at that Ton Ton Ton
Dianetics [ __ ] volcano I'm gonna take
over yeah I was like thinking that I was
gonna be able to figure out all my
mental problems through this book and
then I got on the list and like every
week I got some new workshop to go to or
this I just so they're just amazed just
mailers mail just mail this is the 90s
that's all they did was just mail you
[ __ ] and but oh my god I got someone to
this it wasn't until I moved and one of
the reasons why when I moved I didn't
forward my mail I contacted because of
Dianetics I'd get so much [ __ ] from them
was that what [ __ ] was so much [ __ ] it
was like letter after letter more than
like the grocery store also it started
freaking me out that they knew where I
was like it bothered me it bothered me
like it bothered me that I was on a list
I was on a list of someone who bought
the book but didn't go to any classes
and they knew where I was like maybe I
could get him maybe they were just knock
on his door hey do you want to clean up
your brain hey come on we've got the
solution don't you want to be a volcano
that's scary bro yeah